[Music]
in tourists in trouble news submitted
live pineapple pizza yeah I like coin I
like it too actually just like the
embalm the riches these are you loving
and hating I hate it I think it's like a
good in-between kind of like ginger is
in between your sushi so all within my
pepperoni Alan said pepperoni sushi
pizza are you like three slices of that
and then one slice of Hawaiian and I go
back to my pepperoni
yes it's a pellet cleanser because you
got the sweet and savory but I rather
have the salty pizza I don't like a
juicy pizza like the pineapple juice
you know I do see Pete's I think tomato
hasn't wanted no what about the peepers
in it Italy like sweet juicy also just
like a select well that's good because
there's more pineapple pizza for us yeah
have you had a encho V pizza I've ever
had any people well add something say
Chinese tourists were arrested after
giving the Hitler salute no no dinner
you're gonna get arrested
what were they doing that how are you
doing it in Germany Germany right
government you see I'm not in Germany
what's wrong with that that's a part of
their history it's just the physical
movement but it has so many negative
memories and attachment to it
but when I go to like Japan I date I do
this in pictures
cuz it's a part of the culture I don't
have to do that yeah it's already like
oh by Mike I want to do even more then
you just look like a funny guy I can't
do that
I was the last names not expensive but
yeah I guess it is offensive right I did
it it's essentially you know like the
Nazis have their old gang sign right
they got their like the [ __ ] Heil
Hitler [ __ ] like what do we got like
this right hand over your heart we would
know like what is our thing you know
America America yeah damn don't [ __ ]
kill me guys but Nazis but Nazis though
they had some cool [ __ ] going on like
they had dojin GoBot Gabbana's yesterday
these things and he's not uh in terms of
the branding the branding was on point
branding only I'm just jealous that we
didn't return the calling card like so
like Nazis had their hand
signals right I wish America had their
own [ __ ] like we had like you know how
like in the civil rights movement the
Black Panthers and everybody had the
[ __ ] fist like the [ __ ] unity yeah
like that right hippie this piece yeah
they had the piece the Hawaiians with
the [ __ ] Jacques you know like what
do we have what we had didn't tell
America oh we don't have nothing
oh we don't really have anything so not
a sign and make loudest one that's the
rockers that's rock that's rock for
spider-man one of the two on what is
this lead Devil's horns and this is a
leg I love you
that's right see Italians but the people
people people it be nothing so yeah they
got pretty people to be pretty pretty
pretty right I didn't see anyone do that
in Italy I learned it all family guys it
seems like not everyone has one though I
don't think you have to have you know
nobody wants that's what I'm saying yeah
Jamar Allen I got to make one up it's
this one that looks like a like a was it
like Pacific Islander like what is that
Kakaako you can't call her [ __ ] haha oh
it's a haka this is you want this into
these Alliance can we just get a chat
that's [ __ ] Wolverine comes out there
he starts with the [ __ ] eggs you're
come on did you really know you have to
greet like this no it's kind of that's
whack which is a put on each one
no I gotta give you something you can't
give them a Pocahontas I know cuz it
looks familiar to me how much is it is
like that no that's fine we're not a
violent nation that's all the bad guys
in the movies this this is the one
that's a Fiat Emir up and down there I
just made a little bit better yeah so
these two Chinese tourists they were
arrested in Berlin for making the [ __ ]
Heil Hitler
halt I'm trying to love China like I
really it like I know I talk a lot of
[ __ ]
comes from personal experience okay so
I've just been traumatized despite PTSD
for some time you're changing the
generation you got any baby I love it
I'm trying I know I'm trying not to be
negative but when you guys make we have
to [ __ ] like this this is why the [ __ ] I
have to speak my mind see you guys
[ __ ] stop there I can't even
understand what the hell you're saying
can you translate go don't even watch
this channel yeah I knew this really
that well the Japanese there was a
Chinese we have mainland China fans
because during I ran into some home and
I remember I was at the grocery store
and into this hot ass [ __ ] mainland
family and I was like I was like HS I
was like so I'm going to teach you the
difference between Asian that's that's
what you call a mainland Chinese - Jenny
paid under your breath don't like The
Beverly Hillbillies and then after I
finished shopping the kids came up and
be like hey Joe I love your show man
and I was like I'm a [ __ ] dick one
can help it you know like fog I'm
becoming racist every single day like
the more I meet them
you know what happened the other day a
[ __ ] mainline guy he brought
cigarettes into my [ __ ] apartment
complex smoked it inside the elevator
shut down the damn elevator and the
whole apartment alarm went crazy and
everybody had to leave and we are like
standing there in a line did he say
sorry
no he [ __ ] panicked and ran over one
you know I mean he's on cameras of
course so then she you know the we got
yeah we all caught him we live there
yeah he lives there what a [ __ ]
that's my long to post you know on a
random note though Joe we're both
wearing shirts that have Shiva so it's
on and there's three of them
oh [ __ ] that was really random yeah it's
really random ends like both black shirt
and both Asian and we man is made of
China yeah
probably I'd have like sleep so random
that's all cool yes I was Chinese
tourists they did it right outside of
the German parliament come on by okay
and then they didn't go there was
another set of [ __ ] Chinese people
that went to I don't know what island
and they were taking away all the
[ __ ] coral and garlic oh in Thailand
come on people have some [ __ ] respect
yeah so they were arrested and released
on a bail of six hundred dollars each so
the men there's 36 and 49 so sounded
like you said - well 36 and 49 yeah
they're all so cool to know that change
I thought there were like 20 year-old no
36 and 49 years what if they're a fan of
Nazis so they just associate you learn
anything like China though right there's
a lot of like Asian people like dressing
up like Nazis and stuff like that you
have the most random effects I just look
it up there's like fashion shows right
right yeah yeah I'm not the only one
tripping like because you're ignorant
and they just think it looks cool and
they don't know the history of that one
brand boy - have you seen that fashion
Brandon Scott Lee has the Eagle that the
naughty news it has a different logo it
does have a swastika but it's really
close it's like really bad what might be
your brother right well no I but this
one photo that stands out to me
China's what obsession with Hitler
you're right there's a moment no idea by
the way I saw this thing and they really
like mine car I feel like [ __ ]
Davidson say that [ __ ] was [ __ ] Davis
oh yeah they're all wearing it limbo
session yes it's like a fashion thing
being edgy Taylor's always connected to
like bad rebel culture and stuff well be
for good reason has bad guys I think at
the time that that whole thing was
happening like the country was really
[ __ ] up and he was like everyone's
saving grace and then he just went
[ __ ] berserk and started
experimenting and trying to cleanse
what's so bad about Hitler the fact that
he picked a [ __ ] ethnicity or yeah I
take the specific
ethnicity and he was just like we need
to get rid of these people
we need experiment all these people
there's not people they did that here
and they killed all these Native
Americans and that's that but no one
gets the rap for that white people a lot
that's true I don't know I'm just kind
of like you know everybody has done bad
[ __ ] yeah everyone has you know there's
probably some [ __ ] Ming Dynasty
people that went over and [ __ ] up some
Tang Dynasty people and massacred some
other people
I got good nice and mostly sustainable
you know I think because that so
whatever you're saying in history was at
a time where the education wasn't I
didn't know any better yet he didn't
know any better name was literally
dog-eat-dog right so they weren't
civilized the way that we're supposed to
be civilized
at least when Hitler was around so now
that that we have that it's like [ __ ]
the human race knows better why are we
treating each other like were [ __ ]
animals again like it was so primitive I
think that's what the difference was
Shady
what happened you just changed it so
fast well I I know why it's shady now
it's shady because it's not me on top
like ruling [ __ ] so if it's someone else
trying to come over and take over your
[ __ ] they're the bad guys that's what it
is if you're in peace and not disturbing
anyone else yeah yeah so for example if
we were German and then like let's say
alternate history like let's say we were
German Hitler was our leader he actually
won then guess what America is the bad
guy yes so it just depends on who wins
the war but there was also Germans at
that time who refused to join a Nazi
army and they would get killed too
that's so fun it is probably unethical
yeah hey you guys want to stock any of
us we'll go ahead down to the
description box below and you can follow
us on Instagram and all kinds of stuff
for more videos
[Music]
[Music]